all right vicky
vicki uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up i grew up in
hilda utah and tell me tell me about
your childhood you had both parents
growing up as a kid
my
i don't know if you've heard of the uh
warren jeff
warren jeff's the the mormon polygamous
polygamy
i grew up i was born and raised in the
polygamy
or was that right so one of the
extremist
mormon sex down in uh in southern utah
my dad has two wives and i was home
schooled
first second and third grade actually
first and second grade
then oh first second home school third
grade
private school fourth grade home school
then fifth and sixth
class of home school the seventh and
eighth of the private school
and how many brothers and sisters did
you have
my mom has 14 kids i'm number seven
and then my dad's other wife has nine
it's like 25 sibling drinks
[Music]
so today you're working as a prostitute
well
i've been doing um prostitution or
whatever
bloody work for three years now i
started out as doing
uh bodywork doing bodyweight so it's not
happy ending or anything
i was doing good until i came out here
from utah
and since i've been on here it's been
harder for me and i actually quit doing
the prostitution for a while
for a good year just because it was
i wasn't liking it and but now my um
boyfriend
or xml broke up with me
you're back to it and drugs
are a part of your life now
yeah what's your drug today
today i prefer the
cocaine but it's too expensive so i
usually start
only doing a crystal and heroin
how old were you when you left your
mormon family back in utah
how old was that when i left home yes
when i left home i was 19 19.
yeah i just turned 19 in september
did you leave because you were
uncomfortable with that lifestyle or
i was 10 years old and i knew that i'm
sorry
i was 10 years old and i made my mind i
wasn't sitting
i'm sorry i'm having a hard time
understanding you sorry i was 10 years
old
when i knew it was wrong oh i see yeah
my dad married a lady who was five years
older than me
she was 15 when i was 10. and your dad
was how old
my 40 i think 30 40.
yeah yeah
that's always that for him right there
so
that was the point where you knew
something that's what i knew it wasn't
right and
because he was uh
i don't i'd like he treated my mom like
she was nothing after that
what is your opinion of that whole
religion and that community is is it
i've photographed up there before as
well and i when i've in certain
maybe a different community than yours
but i've seen them as an honest
hard-working bunch that just happened to
have multiple wives
and lots of kids but what's you you you
know it much better than i do what was
your
impression of it
and i
well their heart are working i mean at
least growing up
me personally and never in my family
the girls were all learning how to sew
by the time they're eight years old but
i'm here at
pretty much an adult kind of thing
and i lived on a farm so i was thinking
about the farm animals
milking the cow feeding
garden the eggs feeding the chickens
whatnot and milking the cow as well
we make our own yogurt and cheese
and then i had to bake when i was eight
when i was so when i was eight i also
didn't have to braid hair and
change diapers or not by the time i was
eight years old as well
so but again your the question was
what's your impression of that community
and the religion
i don't know i don't think it's right i
feel like it's uh
too much
um since brainwashing
two months last two months
do you think the the women are do you
feel like the women are
tricked or forced or brainwashed into
marrying at a very early age and
accepting multiple
so all the girls that are there are the
ones that have been born into
already so of course they're already
brainwashed and of course i can think
that that's right
because they're born into that because
that's just like
but so were you and yet you saw yeah i
mean too
and the right view within that to see it
and think for ourselves because not very
many of them could think for themselves
out there
because they'll try to then they'll get
told who's wrong because you know
so the right feeling that i actually
have the strength to
see it not to see it but also
take a step forward and make a move
so where are you living today
today i'm kind of sleeping on the street
down here in skid row yeah are you in a
tent or
well kind of like stay in the car and at
night you just try to get a hotel if i
can get the money
wear rooms and i'll stay in the room at
night
but usually during the day i'm in the
car or
not walking around trying to and
do you see any connection between
the life you lived in utah
in a polygamist
environment and what you're doing today
i don't see any connection with whatever
and i mean
not really because
[Applause]
with where i come from like yeah there's
more than one wife and whatnot
there's no connection whatsoever i can
see there because
but i'm not saying there's a i'm not
saying they do drugs or anything like
that what i'm saying is
that that childhood that you had
somehow may have played a part in in the
fact that you're
addicted to drugs and living on the
street and and working as a prostitute
that's what i'm saying working in the
process two parts no not at all
that just kind of came
honestly i never saw myself doing this
until back before my boyfriend broke up
with me
he got arrested and so i kind of had to
start doing a little more because i
couldn't keep up on the bills
so i started doing it in utah
he supported me though when he found out
but was too happy at first
and how how do you find like the
customers you'll pick up now or they
treat you well or do you have that
that experiences sometimes i have black
experiences here and there
what kind of stuff has happened to you
[Music]
how am um going to get too far i could
say
well the worst that happened here so far
that
that happened to me is they got stranded
kind of where i was at but
it's about an hour and a half from here
took me there
i kind of didn't really pay that well
but
it took care of me noise then he uh
dropped me off my bus stop and drove up
and he told me before i had to take me
down all the way back but he didn't
so mess up
and are you working on your own or with
a pimp i work on my own
by yourself yeah you ever get arrested
or like that
i did once two years ago
and i could have avoided it but
i didn't because i the reason why i got
arrested i didn't listen to my
ex at the time you tried to
lay down and said rolls and laws
wherever it can rule
what to and not to do what to say what
not to say and i was
i was just not about to listen to
anything he had a safety net because i
upset for
some reason and so i
went on my way to make sure i did
nothing that he told me to do and
because of that
i could say his car was a [ __ ]
that date that took his coming out to
take it and i took it anyways and
do you have kids do you have children
and where are they i have one friend
who's raising your son
sorry
did you lose your son to the system
well still a lot of things it'll be
his dad hasn't he's with his dad
i think
sorry
i haven't had a problem with five years
how old is he now
it's just turned seven and june 23.
seven years old do you ever have
contact with your family back in utah
i have a contact with one sister and one
brother
only because the two of them have left
the religion
themselves and that's the only way i
have contact with them
because they're not a part of it anymore
my sister gweny she's the other mom's
oldest daughter
and she's about to have her baby and she
loves the religion as well
looking back at your life what do you
wish had been different
you had a you've had a lot going on with
the family you had in utah and then
since you've gotten to
california
what do i wish you'd become different
yeah what do you wish was different
about your childhood or about your
upbringing a lot
i wish that i would have met
my ex before i ever even
there's a lot of things that were so
different
my ex and i worked together for 10 years
but we met before i got pregnant with my
son but then what happened was
we went really together and i was still
with my baby daddy that time
and i had the opportunity to be with
my ex well my baby dad and my ex his
name is ace
but as for some reason no i wish i would
have gone back with my baby's daddy but
i did
and then i got pregnant with my son
i mean don't get me wrong i love my son
to death it's just that what she could
be in his life
i think sometimes there is i wish i
would have had my son with uh
the guy who recently broke up with me
because at least then i
have in my life here i believe
no
what was the worst time of your life was
time really
i don't know i'll see you
as years go by it feels like each year's
getting worse and worse without my
kid here what was the best
time of your life
i have to say
about six years ago for a good three
years
well see i met my ex in 2011. not my
baby's daddy but my ex his name is ace
he's a black dude
i met him in 2011.
and he just recently broke up with me
about a month ago
i can say that my happiest that i've
been i can remember was
the first couple years when we were
together
he's definitely been the best thing for
me in my life as well
i get healthier when i'm around him
like i start to gain weight
i feel happier and every around me
because i look happier
the reason why i went on together
anymore
he broke up with me because i kind of
i pushed him there you right i pushed
him
to do i kept egging it on
kept doing things
that i knew it upset them
i don't know why but
still to this day
he will come right back and give me if i
dump too but
i don't the reason i don't is because i
feel like i don't deserve them
was there love in the childhood that you
had back in utah
in your family
they're loving mine like did you feel
like you were loved as a child
not really as polite
and growing up even up until
i left home not once did i ever hear
from my siblings or mom or dad
that was beautiful pretty or anything
like that
never once heard him say i was you know
good looking beautiful
i didn't hear the very first person
first time i heard
anyone tell me i was beautiful was that
march to 2011 when i met
ace my ex he's the person to tell me
what's the most important lesson you
think you've learned in life
open your eyes to the blessings that you
have
and you're not taken for granted
he said hey welcome when you open your
eyes if it's gone
i cannot give up that's why i am where i
am today
i believe because i stopped caring
and gave up myself
after i asked my son i got there's
nothing
did not worry more
[Music]
sorry
hi vicky thank you for talking with me
no
sorry it's okay you're going through a
lot
you've been through a lot and you're
going through a lot